حسنًا ، هذا الصباح ، اختراق طبي رائع ،
يسير رجل الآن بعد أكثر
من عقد من تعرضه
لإصابة في الحبل الشوكي بالشلل
أصيبت يونوسكام البالغ من العمر 40 عامًا بجروح في حادث دراجة نارية منذ
أكثر من عقد من الزمان ، مما
منعه من اتخاذ خطوة واحدة
ولكن الآن الأطباء في
ساعدته سويسرا على استعادة قدرته على متابعة
أفكاره
قبل عامين ، وقد تواصلت مع
فريق العلماء في سويسرا
ويمكنني المشاركة في تجربة إكلينيكية
لواجهة دماغية للعمود الفقري حيث وضعوا
غرسات في دماغي وظهري
لتعلم المشي مرة أخرى ، من
المدهش هنا كيف تعمل الغرسات
في الدماغ على تتبع نوايا
الحركات ، صحيح أن ما يفكر فيه في
نقلها يتم نقله لاسلكيًا
إلى وحدة معالجة يرتديها شخص
خارجيًا مثل حقيبة ظهر رأيته
يرتديها هناك ، كما يقول  يمكنه الآن المشي
بطول ملعب كرة القدم
والوقوف دون استخدام يديه لبضع
دقائق حتى أنه يحاول صعود
ونزول السلالم بمفرده